so you know I laid out some principles
when we started the show that I wasn't
going to talk about people that much
specific people except in this space
there have been a couple people that
have have acted really really
dishonestly and I read just a couple
days ago a piece that you wrote about
some of the stuff that reza aslan has
said and i find him to be a profoundly
dishonest player in this space and i see
what he's done to sam harris most of my
audience knows about all of that already
can you explain a little bit about what
your what your stuff is with him uh well
so this was in response to I wrote I
co-wrote a piece with Mohammed saya
who's also works with X Muslims of North
America there was there's a CNN clip
that's been going around and it's making
rounds again
at the CNN clip where Reza Aslan is on
and he talks about FGM
and he talks about Bill Maher and talks
about how FGM isn't and isn't a Muslim
problem it's an African problem female
genital mutilation we should just say it
for the few people that may not write it
yeah and he and then he he puts a few
other things out there as evidence that
Muslim majority countries are actually
not that bad for women including you
know they're some women that are heads
of state and etc so I wrote a piece
about it
Co wrote a piece about it and publish it
on the Friendly Atheist and it got this
big response because I feel like there
were some people that a good amount of
people that were wanting somebody to
pick up on these things that they felt
like weren't true I think they couldn't
say this and we said it and we laid it
out there and we laid out very clearly
about why the points that he was making
were dishonest at the you know at the
least and I think in a lot of ways he's
aware of what he's doing so he said he
said many times that you know Mohammed
he sought something to the extent of you
know how Mohammed freed the slaves he
said things in in that vein quite a few
times and that is extremely dishonest
that is not true it's just not true all
Mohammad did would say the
you can't enslave another Muslim and
there are many people many scholars who
think that this actually encouraged the
spread of the slave trade because
suddenly you're in Arabia and you can't
slave and enslave another Muslim so you
have to go out and you makan you have to
go to various places to get your slaves
he did that you didn't condemn slavery
he had slaves he had sex slaves and so
there it and supposedly reza aslan is a
scholar I don't even know about that
whole thing I can't I can't waste any
more brain cells on that guy basically
right it's just so it's very frustrating
and talking about it as less and I'm
getting tired of it myself just to see
that oh you just to just make stuff up
sometimes but do you think that's part
of the reason I wanted to mention it
because I knew you were gonna be
exhausted by talking about it because
it's like you write your piece and then
you want to move on and that's how I've
felt a lot of with a lot of my
interviews I interviewed Sam and I
wanted to move on to some other stuff
but then these guys just further the
attack but do you think that that's part
of it that they throw out what I would
call just basic [ __ ] or they throw
out these lies and these smears and then
you have to spend a tremendous amount of
your time and your energy and your
lifeforce basically either defending
yourself or or the honest critiques that
you're making absolutely and I think
this is the experience of almost
everyone who has critique Islam in any
way and which is why we're seeing
there's just a lack of it there's just a
lack of it everywhere I mean there's a
lack of scholarship if you try to really
study this and I have there there isn't
that much out there that is truly
secular that is looking at it from a
very outsider's perspective there were
some efforts to do so but they've now
been painted as Orientalist
and therefore bad and therefore
right-wing of course so and so there's
that study sort of stopped around the
time that those smears began and those
associations with this is bigotry if
you're going to conflate this with any
kind of negative any kind of negative
anything so it's I think it's it's
really unfortunate because a scholarly
pursuit of looking into you know what
Islam is how did it began what Muhammad
did all of that I mean that has just it
suffered it suffered tremendously
because of people's fears of being seen
as a bigoted racist what
so a lot of I think a lot of people
haven't haven't really reached out
haven't really said the things that they
want to say reveal the knowledge that
they had or even looked into it further
if they wanted to because if they're
they're thinking well this is going to
destroy my career what's the point
yeah and doesn't some of that that fear
of speaking out about this stuff
doesn't that actually show what real
bigotry is if you're afraid to speak out
about saying because you think it's
going to lead to dishonest smearing of
you or really what it's about is
violence to you that's what people
clearly are really afraid I mean I get
emails now every day literally from all
over the world that people are afraid to
speak out so the real bigotry is saying
we're not going to talk about these
people because guess what they can't
control their violent tendencies or
something like that right alright and
well it's interesting because a lot of
people said this about about the Charlie
Hebdo cartoonists they said well they
should have seen it coming
John Kerry John Kerry our Secretary of
State just in the last day or so said
basically you know there was some sort
of rationalization it's unbelievable
it's absolutely unbelievable and to say
that that you have it coming when you
are exercising a right exercising a
right that is given to you in the
country that you live and what's the
point of having a right if I can't test
it to its extremes that's the point and
in a lot of ways what Charlie Hebdo did
for example was not that extreme it was
exactly the same treatment that they
were giving Christianity and they were
giving that exact same treatment to to
Islam so it to me it seemed like they
were they were making it fair they were
saying that hey we're not biased and
we're gonna apply the same the same
scrutiny to all religious forms and they
did that and I thought that were very
fair about it and then they have smeared
in so many ways yeah and not only did
they do it out of equality where they
made fun of Orthodox Jews and made fun
of Christianity I think I'm going to
slightly butcher this but I think it was
something like 80% were about
Christianity when they did covers
related to religion and only something
like 10 percent were about Islam but I
don't quote me fully on that but also
what people fail to realize with Charlie
Hebdo is that it was satire about the
things that are wrong with religion they
weren't mocking Muslims as people just
as they weren't mocking Christians as
people but they were mocking archaic
age-old ideas
right absolutely in many ways I think it
can be seen as an anti-racist
publication and and and a lot of people
made a lot of good cases for this and
it's difficult because we're
english-speaking people and we don't
really understand the context of how how
they how you know these publishers do
what they do in France but I think when
you look at it from in from a very
unbiased perspective you'll find that
there are anti-racist in a lot of ways
and it was horrible to hear people say
well they had it coming because it it
made it seen not only that they were
stupid for doing what they're doing
instead of brave which is what they were
but but also that Muslims are beasts and
animals and we cannot expect them to
behave in the same way we would expect
everyone else to behave right and that's
what I mean about this sort of soft I
think this is what Bill Maher refers to
as the soft bigotry of low expectations
if you say anything about these people
that's going to upset them well then you
have to just expect that they're gonna
kill you and that that's crazy and also
you would live in a constant hostage
crisis with a certain set of the
population absolutely and that's that I
mean that's exactly the feeling of I
think a lot of those people who tell you
that you know I'm afraid to speak out it
is absolutely taking away from the
humanity of Muslims too because it's
turning them into beasts that we cannot
we cannot say hey this is a standard
that we expect from everybody we expect
you to be able to handle this and that
they listen to it okay and we actually
haven't pushed it we actually haven't
said that hey this is totally acceptable
and this is totally what how we run
things in the Western world and this is
what we expect out of everyone who is
here in the Western world we expect you
to respect us especially not respond in
a violent way brennick haven't had that
conversation so is part of it simply
that for the people that are the real
Islamic extremists they simply at the
end of the day no matter how much my
friends on the Left want to blame
everything on American foreign policy
and all of this stuff no matter you know
Boko Haram killed about 160 people last
week it had nothing to do with American
foreign policy right yet this is they
always blame everything on America and I
don't deny as I said at the top of the
show I don't deny that foreign policy
has mucked up a lot of things but this
is where people on the left just
complete
we fail right absolutely and I'm I'm
very I'm sick of hearing that
colonialism is to blame for all of this
I'm sick of it that one particular thing
I hear all the time that this is it's
because of colonialism and it doesn't
really make any sense when you look into
it and again not to say not to say that
colonialism was in a horrible horrible
practice I mean I'm from the South Asian
subcontinent so pollen eyes by England
and it was horrible what England did to
to South Asia and and the effects the
long-range effects it had on South Asia
but they're are so easy to throw away
the colonialism excuse when it comes to
radical Islam I mean I mentioned two of
these in my speech which is that Muslims
have been doing this sort of thing
violence justifying violence in the name
of religion since way before colonialism
ever came into the picture right that
it's existed for a long long time and
when you say colonialism is the only
thing to blame you are denying that that
whole history existed but there were so
many people that were oppressed in the
name of Islam it's happened before and
it's happening again it's the same sort
of thing yeah did you by any chance see
a piece that Faisal Scytale Matar put up
a couple days ago on Facebook where he
he writes sort of a satirical piece
saying that he's playing this this
Muslim extremists saying this is why I'm
doing it I'm doing it for religion and
it's basically this argument with him
and one of these regressive lefties
saying no no no it's not because the
religion and he keeps saying no no I'm
doing it cuz our religion and they go
back and forth and go back and forth and
at the end the guys like you know what
do I have to do to prove to you that
this is in the name of religion I mean
even after Paris which I want to talk to
about in a second the statement that
these guys issued there was a lot of
religious overtones to it
a ton of religious overtones it wasn't
purely you know this bombing in Syria or
whatever well it's I mean it's
astounding to me that at this point
anyone can deny that religion is nothing
to do with it I true III believe that
every there is no one really any serious
intellectual who believes it this has
nothing to do with the religion it has
something you know you can even make the
case that it's a perverted Islam but it
is some aspect of Islamic theology that
they have taken and then perverted at
the very least at the very
that they have done that and I think
that a lot of people play just lip
service they say that this has nothing
to do with the religion I don't think
they believe it I think this is in a lot
of ways a very political loop yeah so I
mentioned this also at the top of the
show but if let's say magically the
United States and the West and France
and England and everybody we all did
whatever it is Isis wants us to do
United mean pull out of that part of the
world whatever else they might want us
to do do have any reason to believe that
suddenly terror would stop or that
things would get better I actually would
see it completely the reverse they would
almost be more emboldened to continue
and I say that as someone that doesn't
even want to be there in the first place
right I agree with you about Isis is a
different animal and if they are they
are very strict about their
interpretation and they look into things
at in a very literal way and if they are
going to look into it as in the way that
you know Islamic thought has progressed
about what you would call the land of
the most believers and land of the
non-believers they are religiously it's
a duty so religious duty to do what they
can't despite Islam to at the whole
globe so they're not going to stop
there's told us they're not going to
stop why can't we just listen to them
and understand that they mean what they
say
yeah and that was the point of faizal's
peace and I got into a fight on Twitter
I try not to fight on Twitter but I got
into a fight with one of my friends on
the Left who kept saying foreign policy
and I kept saying listen to what they're
saying don't listen to me listen listen
to what they tell you so one more I just
want to jump back a little bit before we
get into into Paris so I want people to
understand there's a distinction between
someone like yourself that you consider
yourself an ex-muslim you're a
non-believer versus some of the
Reformers that are still either either
believers or that consider themselves
Muslim someone like imagine Waze
although he said to me that you know he
doesn't want to put up his version of
Islam for anyone else but but there is a
distinction there so there's two brands
of people that we're talking about that
are trying to help here right do you
mean like progressive Muslims and
and well-meaning meaning that there's
there's your branch that's sort of
ex-muslims right you fully you are an
atheist you don't consider yourself part
of the religion versus there are some
that are trying to reform the religion
from the inside is there any sort of
interplay with you guys are people
working together it's hard to tell well
I think that I think it would be
intellectually dishonest for us to work
together in the sense that truly our
aims are different yeah I mean they're
they're similar in some ways right we
want to make sure too we want to
decrease harm in the world we want to
push second layers on push Human Rights
promote it the best we can but our ways
of going about it are so radically
different that I think that it would be
I mean where I'm in contact with with
some of these people and I respect them
tremendously yeah they're doing
wonderful things I just agree with them
there is very little about Islam and
fundamentals of Islam as as as Sam
Harris says that I agree with on any
level and it's hard for me to find any
beauty or or you know compassion or all
these wonderful things that we would
ascribe to something so holy I don't I
don't find that in this text so there
isn't really I disagree with people when
they do say that I'm a little bit
extremist you know people say that well
you cannot expect everyone to just a
pasta is all at once but this is not
what I'm pushing I don't want the Muslim
world to apostatize all at once yeah but
but for me it would be intellectually
dishonest to go about it on any other
way and I actually think that there is I
mean it's atheism and secularism and and
free thought I think we have a very
strong critique of religion something
that is very internally coherent and
ethically coherent and this case is one
worth making and if we're talking about
the marketplace of ideas it's important
that we show our side and we put their
best case out there and a land where
they will land so that that's really
interesting to me so in a weird way your
your brand here is a little is a little
cleaner let's say then the people that
are trying to reform it from the inside
and I don't sense that you're judging
them for that as much as
it really is easier to make a case from
your position because you're just saying
I don't believe in thousand-year-old
books so I'm going to make a case based
on the world as it is sort of and
they're still trying to negotiate and
that's where I see someone like Reza and
where I say he this is someone who's
profoundly dishonest all the time but I
think he's trying to negotiate the world
with this religion and then he uses a
lot of words so nobody knows what he's
talking about but your case is a lot
cleaner even even if I disagreed with
you I would understand the logic more
sensibly I do think that in the case of
somebody like Reza I think it is
condescending towards other Muslims
because I think some people believe that
you know Muslims will never get there
they'll never get to where you are
you're expecting too much I don't think
I'm expecting too much like this is
actually if I was allowed to make this
case most Muslims do not hear anything
similar to what I have to say they will
never hear anything like this I think if
they did I think it would change things
yeah they we don't know yet right and we
don't we don't know that that's the case
right well now you did this show with me
they're gonna say you're working with a
Zionist Nazi and not enough this is
going to help now either